-Can you talk about --
I know you have two new
hopefully "initiatives"
is the right word,
basically the Climate Realit
Project and climate tracing.
-Yeah, thank you. Well,
the Climate Reality Projec
is a project that I starte
back in 2006
with all of the profits from
the movie and book
"An Inconvenient Truth."
And right now, we're in
the middle of our 44th training,
and this is the first
virtual training,
and I was so happy that 14--
more than 14,000 people
applied to join.
We couldn't handle that many
because we don't have
enough mentors
to do that big a group yet
But 10,000 signed up.
We're in the sixth day
of a nine-day training.
And in the nature
of these virtual trainings
you avoid what they call
"Zoom fatigue"
by doing it two hours a day,
basically.
It's a real thing, and --
-I believe it.
-Yeah. And so, it's going
extremely well. Thank you.
And we have people
from 130 countries,
and we give them the facts
about the science,
the causes, the impacts,
the solutions,
and we give them advocacy
and communication skills
even better than what
most of them already have.
And you asked, also, about
the climate trace initiative
Thank you.
This is a new coalition
that is made up of nine tech
organizations and companies.
A lot of brilliant young peopl
engaged in
artificial intelligence
and machine learning.
And our goal is to launch
next June.
We'll have a hard launch
at the beginning of the year
But by next June,
we will have a report
on every significant
greenhouse gas emissions
anywhere in the world --
how much,
who's responsible for it -
and then we'll update it
every six hours.
And the point is to make
these folks accountable
for the first time.
There are a lot of governments
that really have a hard time
understanding
where their own greenhouse
gas emissions are coming from.
There are a lot of companies
that want their supply chain
to scrub out
the global warming pollution
There are a lot of activists
that want to know where
it's coming from.
And there are a lot of investors
who want to take their money
out of companies
that are busy
at destroying the future
of human civilization
and put it into companies that
are facilitating a transitio
to a cleaner and more prosperous
and sustainable world.
-You mentioned Zoom fatigue.
Having been a candidate
for the presidency,
can you imagine what it must
be like for Joe Biden right now,
having to basically campaign
from his home?
It must be so different
from what you experienced.
-Well, it's very different
We haven't seen a campaign
like this one geographically
for a long, long time,
since before the days
of television.
And I think that's he's
handling it extremely well
You know, I'm for him.
And so, you can take my remark
with a grain of salt.
But I really think
he's doing extremely well.
And most people
seem to share that view.
-You -- He maybe was not
the greenest candidate
when there was
a large debate field.
Yet, he seems to be taking
the environment very seriously
on his platform now.
Are you -- You know, obviously
considering how you feel
about it as an issue,
are you optimistic so far
how he would address it
as the President?
-Absolutely. And to put
your comment in perspective,
it's true that
there were other candidates,
like Jay Inslee, prominently
and others, as well,
who had maybe a bolder climate
agenda during the primaries,
but if you look at Joe Biden's
plan during the primaries,
it was miles ahead of what w
have seen in any previous cycle.
And, wisely, he has adopte
some of the best proposals
from his primary opponents
and fully integrated them
into his new plan.
I have enjoyed my conversation
with him
since Joe Biden
secured the nomination.
I'm very happy with
what he has proposed.
There are always a few thing
that I would,
you know,
do a little differently,
go a little farther and faster
But, honestly,
it is a great platform,
and I think it's getting
rave reviews
from most all the folks
who really care about
the climate crisis.
-Obviously, Joe Biden
is far ahead in the polls,
but we should still be
very worried, right?
We can't just rest
on our laurels here
and be happy with a 15-point
lead in a July poll.
-Well, I can confirm that, yes
The actual votes are what
determine the winner.
His lead is a good one.
But after the experience
supporters of the nominee
four years ago had
watching a poll lead
not quite as large as this one
but pretty big
just sort of disappear,
everybody kind of says,
"Well, wait a minute.
I'm not taking anything
for granted."
And I would like to quote
the great departed John Lewis.
He was a dear friend
and such a great champion.
And, also, a climate champion,
by the way.
He and I introduced the very
first environmental justice bill
30 years ago.
And when he crossed
the Edmund Pettus Bridge
for the very last time
last year --
people knew that
he had pancreatic cancer,
and it was
an emotional occasion --
he got to the other side.
And I was watching the interview
on television.
And I got kind of emotiona
hearing him say --
He said, "We've got to vot
like we've never voted before.
And I hope everybody
takes that message to hear
because this will be
a turnout election.
Trump supporters will turn out
And the supporters of Bide
just need to turn out
in even larger numbers.
I kind of think that's the
direction it's headed in
right now.
But nobody should take
a single vote for granted.
-Thank you so much
for your time.
It's always a pleasure
speaking with you.
And hopefully, next time
will be in person.
-I hope so, too. Thanks, Seth.
Keep up the great work.
-All right. All the best.